last week during a taping of the view
probably heard about this co-host Megan
McCain got upset by something on ur
Navarro said and she was filmed storming
off the set as they went to commercial
very dramatic maybe I was come see in a
way that I had no way I don't hire me
what happy was I don't I don't know what
you just said but I said don't scream at
me I'm two feet away we'll be right back
yeah she went right off and I don't know
Andy to me that is so unprofessional you
know maybe what do you mean maybe she
stormed off in the middle of a taping
it's ridiculous yeah look I'm not
defending Megan McCain but sometimes you
do a talk show day after day with
someone who says stupid things I mean I
I can see how you'd reach a breaking
point okay but what it's your job to
have a discussion on television in front
of a live studio audience like the one
we have here you got to do your job
that's the way it is okay I hear you
Conan but sometimes you just can't stand
to hear another word come out of your
co-hosts thinlit never close mouth
yeah like kind of like when you're
forced to interact with the same dull
faced housing the same hollow eyes
decade after decade exactly then one day
you realize you spent your entire
working life treating pre-planned quips
and watered-down riffs with an alcoholic
show puppet it makes you want to punch a
wall sometimes yeah I know the feeling
Andy oh I know the feeling yeah I guess
we both know the feeling Andy
[Music]
hey why don't you tell the people who's
on the show tonight Conan yeah okay
story the CBS series mom on apheresis he
[Applause]
anyone else I'll tell you who else yeah
media Gavin goddamn Matt's is here
[Applause]
why do you tell them what kind of show
it's gonna be oh it's gonna be a great
show Andy stick around we'll be right
back
[Applause]